what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight video before I get started I want
to announce the final two winners of my
Game of Thrones series giveaway many of
you have entered the giveaway but now
only two more people can win and those
winners are Bobby singer and Gary
Hawkins congratulations Bobby and Gary
just make sure you private message me on
here or you can send me an email and let
me know what season you want I have to
thank everyone for participating and if
you didn't win something this time don't
worry because I will announce a new
giveaway in my next video I haven't
decided what it will be yet but I'll
think of something cool before I record
the next one but let's get into today's
topic and I'm gonna have to warn all of
you before I get started I am about to
read to you something and I don't know
where the hell it came from and I have
no idea how legitimate it is if you do
end up turning off the video after I
read the first sentence then I
completely understand but this may
entertain some of you in another way
that probably wasn't intended one of my
subscribers sent me an email last night
and this email had an entire outline for
season 8 there was no link in the email
so I'm not even sure if this person
wrote it out themselves or not it may be
a collection of theories or it might be
an alleged plot leaked or it could just
be some really bad fanfiction personally
I would lean more towards the latter at
first I was just going to delete the
email but after I started reading it I
figured what the hell I can't keep this
to myself let me share it with the rest
of the community I'm sure you won't pick
this apart it every chance you get so
without further ado I present to you an
episode by episode season 8 outline
season 8 episode 1 torment and Barrack
returned to Winterfell when inform songs
of the wall has collapsed and that
Viserion is an undead dragon now word is
then sent to white Harbor where John and
Danny are based and to King's Landing
the undead army marches south along the
east coast
Sansa sends word to the other houses to
prepare defenses burned their dead
equipped dragonglass weapons and
possibly returned to Winterfell for a
final fight slash defense a month or so
passes in the last hearth is overrun by
the knight king's army john learns how
to ride Ragle now and his fighting /
flying out of
Harbor the living dragons are pretty
well held back though because of the
night Kings javelin skills and the
potential for losing another dragon
Circe's betrayal is obvious now no
troops are supplied Theon and his small
crew are sailing east after you're on
Jaime arrives in Winterfell
at first he has brought before Sansa and
is threatened with death Brienne vouches
for Jaime and urges Sansa to take him at
his word Jaime and Brienne joined forces
and will be part of the main army they
will do some major work / fighting with
their Valyrian steel Jaime also offers
his commander battlefield knowledge
meanwhile in white Harbor Danny tells
Tyrion that she is in love with Jon Snow
and may be pregnant with his child Terry
and then manipulates Varys into
suggesting to John and Danny that going
and trying one last time to issue a pact
with Cersei directly might work with
Vasari on now fighting for the night
king they will need every bit of
resources they can get John insists that
he should be the one to go alone and do
this Jon fly south on regel to meet with
Cersei Cersei seems open and receptive
at first likely mentions a comment about
how she has heard that Dany is pregnant
and that she understands the importance
of new life more than ever as she is
pregnant as well Cersei thanks John for
meeting her and also thanks him for
making things so easy for her John and
Rhaegar then both killed foreshadowing
for this one Tyrion noted how easily Jon
handed over his weapons to Danny's army
it was also mentioned multiple times
that if he was John's hand he would have
eyes against it John keeps the stark
blood tradition of traveling south to
King's Landing and being killed tyrion
who is a lion had his heart pierced by
Danny loving John instead of him as such
this was the second forging of a dragon
/ child slash sword and y reg all will
die / be broken
it will also be Danny's treason for love
episode 2 karhold is overrun by the
night king and the White Walkers Euron's
fleet lands and Essos and they meet with
the golden company the two forces are
combined and Fiona is still at sea
closing in on them John's body is sent
to Winterfell to be put into the crypts
Arya is finally
you know John but he is dead and his
heart has stopped foreshadowed lying
this season from Sansa Tyrion tries to
console Dany and advises her that there
is another way to reach peace with
Cersei / the Lannisters Dani should
marry him and what their house is bound
then Cersei would be more inclined to
help
Tyrion even says that they can claim her
child as his and he will raise it as his
own if they are married the child will
still have a rightful claim to the
throne and Casterly Rock legacy and
succession was mentioned this season as
well between the two of them also it
might prevent Cersei from harming the
child as kin slaying is still
theoretically and no no Danny rejects
Tyrians proposal and especially the
timing of it disgusted by him and his
actions Danny may even have Tyrion put
into a cell under suspicion of betrayal
all of the characters from white Harbor
travelled to Winterfell for John's
funeral and because the undead horde is
drawing ever closer to it John's body is
then returned to the Winterfell crypts
with Ned's already there they are
reunited again which leads to bran and
Sam revealed that John is actually Aegon
Targaryen and he had the rightful claim
to the Iron Throne they indicate that
his child will not be the heir though as
it would be a bastard
Tyrion and Danny will exchange looks
berrak will step forward and indicate
that he realizes his purpose now to pass
his soul to Jon and the books this would
be undead Catelyn Varys protests loudly
he despises fire magic above all else he
may even try to restrain slash attack
beric Dondarrion most of the people in
attendance are horrified or bothered at
the idea of bringing the dead back to
life they are currently in the war with
the undead after all and Barrett points
out that he was helping them this whole
time and he is a fire white Davos
finally reveals that Jon has already
been revived once before and was fully
committed to stopping the night king
Daenerys commands barrack to bring him
back
berrak performs the kiss and jon is back
again Dany is at first hesitant but
eventually overjoyed Tyrion is pissed
off and Varys is horrified Jon is made
aware of his lineage in a dragon
Targaryen has been awoken from Stone the
Crypt by Ozora hi Danny
commend episode three Danny mentions
that that was the final straw and she
will make sure to execute Cersei as soon
as possible
Daenerys has Varys executed as she
believes it was his idea to send John to
meet with Cersei in the first place and
he was the one person protesting John's
resurrection the hardest
Theon's forces land and assault Euron's
a large battle breaks out your on side
starts to gain an advantage but then
Melisandre shows up with reinforcements
from volantis
Theon side is victorious and he is able
to rescue Yara either Theon or Yara will
then make a deal with Mel's forces and
they will agree to transport them back
to Westeros John and Danny announced
that they will try to be married as soon
as possible because John won't know when
and if he will die again during this
Great War and he won't want his child to
be born a bastard like he thought he was
Danny and John's forces unite under John
as the true king of Westeros no this
wedding may be done in secrecy was Sam
documenting it for The Citadel the
dreadfort is overrun by the knight
king's army word of Euron's defeat
reaches Westeros Cersei is pissed about
losing her army and she makes a comment
to Qyburn that there are more than one
way to win a war and she stole has plans
to win the episode ends with John and
Danny happily exchanging vows episode
for Theon Yara and Melisandre screw
arrive in Westeros with the undead
closing in on Winterfell
brain tries to warg into the night king
to prevent his creation accidentally
supplies the night king with the
three-eyed raven warding powers and it's
kinda linked to the night king the
undead reached Winterfell and the Great
War Between the living in the dead is
waged Jon Brienne and Jaime are the main
Valyrian steel squad on the ground
fighting the Hound ginjury tormund
barrack grey worm Meera and Jorah are
all fighting as well
Dany is keeping herself and drug on is
safe from the fighting as they can if
she and rogue on fall in or joined the
undead than they are really screwed
Danny might go and fight regardless
Sean's and Bryan tried to form the best
defense possible bran is providing all
the best details he can through Raven
worgen in Sansa is commanding the army
accordingly grey worm will be
and or turned into a white Walker the
white Walker slash night king will
resurrect astark corpses in Winterfell
Arya will help defend brain and saw ins
are from the undead and Theon Yara and
Melisandre screw will arrive to join the
fight at one point the seven will all be
fighting together against the undead Jon
as the father Danny as the mother Jaime
as the warrior Gendry as the Smith
Brienne as the maid Melisandre as the
Crone and Arya as the stranger during
the big fight the night king will spot
Jon on the ground and he will land to
fight him face to face the night king
will fight Jon one-on-one and John will
be mortally wounded and ghost will die
in the fight as well as the night king
is over top of Jon relishing his victory
Jaime will charge him Vasari on will
spot Jaime and engulf him in a blue
flame almost seen foreseen the same as
when Jaime charged Danny would rogue on
Jaime will not jump out of the way this
time instead he will burst through the
flames and kill the night king Jaime
will burn to ash and all that will be
left will be his flaming golden hand and
his broken Valyrian steel sword it was
one half of ice after all this will
complete Jaime's prophecy of being the
last man in the Kingslayer the undead
will all perish and everyone will be
relieved Brienne will look over top of
Jaime's Ash and say something like I
swore an oath to protect him may even
hold him as his body decays to ash he
did want to die in the arms of the woman
he loved after all everyone will rush
over to Jon as he has his last few
breaths Jon will pass Longclaw back to
Jorah and tell him to protect Danny and
his baby Jorah will promise to do so
there will be a great celebration as the
fight with the undead is over however
everyone will be sad that so many Jon
Jamie and grey worm are gone
episode 5 Cersei will receive news of
Jaime's death and be heartbroken
everyone will be mad at Cersei for her
betrayal and Danny will be super pissed
that Cersei has tried to take everything
from her slash kill Jon the army heads
for King's Landing but Jon is left
behind in Winterfell Songza will command
the ground forces and Danny will attack
by air just like the last rebellion the
Lannisters will open the
Eight's they will even march out of
King's Landing and appear to be heading
back to Casterly Rock they will tell the
northern army that they are disgusted by
Cersei and she is no Queen of theirs
they will point back to the red keep
she's all yours
even the mountain will be seen marching
away the ground forces will march up to
the Red Keep and we'll start smashing
down the doors Danny will spot Cersei
atop the Red Keep and will grow
impatient with all the archers and army
gone Danny will fly her dragon up to the
top of the Red Keep and she will command
drug on to burn Cersei alive but once
Danny gets close she will realize that
it's not Cersei
it's her handmaiden in disguise the Red
Keep and most of King's Landing will
explode in wildfire the debris from the
explosion will injure Dany and row going
badly
jørgen will set down inside the throne
room but just as a note from the giant
fiery blaze Dany will likely emerge
unharmed but drogon will be dead slash
consumed Dany will relive her vision
from the house of the undying she will
walk towards the iron throne which now
has snow falling on it but she won't
claim it the trauma of her injury /
emotional loss of her last dragon drogon
plus John will be too much for her and
she will start bleeding between her legs
of the remaining ground forces that
weren't killed in the Wildfire explosion
Jorah will find Danny Danny may be
rushed away somewhere like a tower but
regardless nobody else will be around
and she will order him to help save her
baby Jorah will likely perform a
c-section so that the cut looks like a
bleeding star or at the very least help
deliver the baby
Dany will hold the baby with tears of
joy and will whisper something into
jours ear
his name is Rhaegar Jorah will pick up
the baby and Danny will die to touch the
light she must pass beneath the shadow
Jorah will carry the baby away but he
will tell everyone that Dany has died
and that he wasn't able to save the
little baby this will be the third
attempt at forging Lightbringer bonding
her soul with the one she loves
Melisandre will show up and take the
baby from Jorah and walk away somewhere
possibly another flame will be shown
episode 6 Cersei and her Lannister army
will either be a Casterly Rock
or maybe the final battle will be at
Harrenhal regardless due to the cutting
off of the
northern forces by the wildfire beta
Kings Landing in the defense of the
castle / keep it will be an ear even
battle the Northern Alliance is led by
Sansa and they will realize that Tyrion
is missing in as reportedly with Cersei
the battle ensues in the northern army
will win
Cersei the mountain and maybe Tyrion
will all be holed up and will eventually
be forced to surrender flash forward a
few months and everyone is rebuilding
Sansa has been declared the queen of
Westeros and King's Landing in the wall
are being rebuilt Brienne is the Lord
Commander of the Queen's Guard and she
will fill out Jaime's page in the Lord
Commander book with a smile on her face
proud of everything that he did Davos is
now hand to the Queen bran will be
declared forced to be the Lord of
Winterfell and Meera is on her way to
becoming a lady of Winterfell after all
a stark must always remain in Winterfell
Gendry will likely be legitimized and be
Lord of storms end Theon or Yara will be
the Lord / Lady of Pyke the final war
trial will happen most of the characters
will be in attendance for this and so
Anza will be sitting over the trial and
bran will be by her side Cersei and
Tyrion will come out in shackles
probably shackled together and so she
will be very pregnant by this point
Cersei will be first up and she will be
accused of her crimes but she will
retort with something along the lines of
sheep can't judge a lion only the gods
can judge me I demand a trial by combat
she will choose the mountain as her
champion and he will be retrieved from
the prison cells sunzha will look over
the crowd and the Hound will step
forward which will lead to claw game
Bowl the fight will be fantastic and the
Hound will win Cersei will be told that
she will be executed immediately after
the trial Tyrion will be told of the
crimes he is accused of in Tyrion will
explain that he has been tormented and
cursed ever since he committed his first
true crime when he became a kin slayer
and killed his own father he will
explain that everything he did was to
redeem himself to his family and
protecting his future niece nephew was
the only way he could do it he will also
profess that he was in love with Danny
and wanted to marry her as well he will
explain that he also
cared for John and nothing could make
him feel worse than he already feels
bran will chime in actually Tywin wasn't
your father at first Tyrion will be very
relieved that means that he isn't a
Kingslayer
he isn't a monster he always thought he
was then brain will reveal that his
father was actually Aerys Targaryen
Tyrion will breakdown that means that he
actually betrayed and was responsible
for the death of his half nephew Jon and
his half sister Daenerys and their child
he actually betrayed half his family in
the name of protecting the other half of
his family as Tyrion is breaking down
Cersei will make some comment that
ignites him probably something like a
new a disgusting dwarf like you couldn't
be my true brother or you still killed
our mother whatever it is he will lash
out at Cersei and strangle her with the
shackles around his wrists he will
scream at her and choked her until she
stops breathing
Cersei thought the prophecy was broken
and stopped fearing Tyrion when she was
pregnant with her fourth baby but she
never delivered the baby in she was
killed by the valonqar / younger brother
Shaun's ax will be disgusted with Tyrion
in his actions but will give him one
last chance at redemption which Tyrion
will take he will choose to take the
black his final shot will be staring off
of the wall he will finally be able to
brood as well as Jon filled with anguish
and inner conflict Arya will turn down
the chance to finally be a knight in the
Queen's Guard instead she will travel
west to see what is west of Westeros Sam
will return to the Citadel and will make
some comment to the other masters about
how it will take him a long time to
write these events down he will probably
say some cheesy line about calling it a
Song of Ice and Fire
or a game of Thrones he may become grand
maester and reside in King's Landing
or Winterfell or Castle black more time
passes and the children of the forest
come to meet bran
they thanked him for everything that he
has done but they point out that the
night King wasn't purely evil he was
actually trying to protect them from the
great other as they talk we see a scene
of Jorah and he is somewhere warm likely
with lemon trees Geor is holding a child
and it's Jon and Danny's baby it's alive
and well but since Jon and possibly
Danny died and were birth
brought back the life using fire slash
blood magic something isn't quite right
we look closer at the child in its eyes
are the same design and pattern as the
knight King but instead of glowing blue
the eyes are glowing red after all
he isn't the knight king he is light
bringer the children of the forest tell
us in Brian that the child is going to
usher in a long summer filled with fire
and blood they will tell brand that
they're gonna need his help to stop the
great other and this is when the show
will end I don't know what the hell that
was that I just read